Speaker 1: The conspiracies about the Joe
Biden and Mike Pence, classified documents,
situations are growing. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is now suggesting that Joe Biden was set up with
the documents by Democrats because Democrats
don't want Biden to run again. Let's start
with this clip, then I'll remind you of the
one from two days ago where Tucker had his
own conspiracy theory about this.
Speaker 2: Because this criticism
from Democrats of Mr. Biden and his
handling of classified documents.
Speaker 3: Well, their their right to say those
things. But it also makes me wonder something
else that that other people have been wondering,
are we seeing a setup for them to try to get Joe
Biden not to run for president and perhaps make
way for someone else to run for president in 2024?
I think those are those are interesting things
to think about. But I'm glad to see, you know,
Democrats, senators and different Democrats
are just claiming what is absolutely true,
how reckless and irresponsible. It shows that he's
not fit for office. I'll say it again, impeach Joe
Biden. And now we just have more reasons to do so.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, of course, very, very quiet.
Is Marjorie Taylor GREENE on the Mike Pence
thing? You know, sometimes when there's a
conspiracy theory, you can plausibly come up with
some kind of motive, but no further evidence. I
don't even think the motive makes sense here.
And what I mean by that is maybe I'm naive.
There are many fair criticisms of Joe Biden. I
don't think Joe Biden would be irrational if.
The establishment insiders, advisers,
trusted people, came to him and said, listen,
you shouldn't run for reelection and here's why. I
think if that was actually presented to Joe Biden,
because top Democrats believed it to be true, I
really do believe Joe Biden would listen. I don't
think you would need to try to push him out of
running for reelection by creating a fake scandal,
by planting documents. I just don't see any
reason why you would need to do that. Now,
one of the other important things to consider is,
is this a confession for Marjorie Taylor GREENE?
Because oftentimes allegations from Republicans
about things Democrats supposedly did are actually
confessions of things that they did. We found
that out very quickly in the 2020 election. So
maybe it did happen, but it's actually Republicans
who did it. I don't know. But the very same people
furious about what happened with Biden seem to be
silent about what happened with Mike Pence. Now,
as a reminder, this is not the only conspiracy
theory regarding classified documents. Two days
ago, I played this clip from you for you where
Tucker Carlson had the idea that the Joe the
it's hard to keep up. Now, the Mike Pence
documents were set up to make Trump look
bad and take attention away from Joe Biden.
Speaker 4: He said that a few times. Then just
days ago, Mike Pence sent his personal attorney
to search his family's home in Carmel, Indiana,
for classified documents.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: Now, if Mike Pence didn't think
of classified documents, why would he send
his lawyer to go look for classified
documents? We can't say for certain,
but it's entirely possible. In fact, it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do this
by federal prosecutors who are trying to build
a case against his old boss, Donald Trump. Now,
the point would be to show that not every federal
official walks off with state secrets. Donald
Trump was uniquely evil in that regard, as in
so many others. See, Mike Pence didn't do it.
So if that was the plan and we
suspect that it was, it backfired
spectacularly. Because Mike Pence's lawyer.
Speaker 1: If this is actually what happened
and we have no evidence for it, it is
completely irresponsible conjecture that
I just came up with 5 minutes ago and they put
it on my teleprompter for me. But let's assume
that it's true just for the sake of argument.
Speaker 4: He discovered classified documents.
He immediately loaded these documents into
his car and drove them back to Washington
to hand them over to authorities. Yeah.
Speaker 1: One of the things about most
of these types of conspiracy theories is that
they are either falsifiable or unlikely to ever
be proven or disproven. And of course, we already
know the difficulty of actually disproving some of
these conspiracy theories. That's a whole other
question. And so these exact types of conspiracy
theories are often used by the right to dupe and
to propagandize their viewers. Also on falsifiable
conspiracy theories often are self-reinforcing in
the sense that conspiracy theories are often based
on premises that can't be disproven. You can't
prove a negative. And what that means is whether
or not the theory is true, the people that follow
it have absolutely no way to verify that. If you
go with this one. Right, that the Tucker one.
Well, they this was all in order to help Donald
Trump. Well, there's absolutely no communications
that suggests that the Pence stuff was to
help to hurt Donald Trump. Rather, we found no
communications, no documents. There's absolutely
no proof. Law enforcement hasn't found anything.
It's because they're in on it. The very people who
did it covered up the evidence of the fact that
they did it. And falsifiable and falsifiable.
And that makes it self-reinforcing in many ways.
They're not stopping folks. They're not stopping.
And it is dangerous. We will have all of these
clips. If you're a masochist and you actually
were just listening today, but you want to see
what Tucker and Marge look like while saying
this horrible nonsense. You can find the clips
on our YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show or on our Instagram by
searching Instagram for David Pakman show.